and in the future if I want to say
something funny or witty or do an
impression I will no longer ever do any
of those things
does that include that's what she said
yes wow that is really hard you really
think you can go all day long well you
always left me satisfied in smiling huh
that's what she said we need two
Undercovers at the DeKalb Street
warehouse party uh Boyle you're already
in costume as Joy Behar I'm Mario Batali
okay and Santiago you go with them yes
sir
damn it Santiago I know that you hate
Halloween but stick with beat and I
promise you you will love it
can you magically make everyone kind
sober and fully dressed kind sober and
fully dressed
good news everyone we found the name of
Santiago's sex tape Jim no thanks I'm
good that's what she said huh oh my
mother's coming that's what she said no
fine
I'll get my stuff but this better not
bite me in the ass better not bite me in
the ass name your sex tape but seriously
thank you so much for your help
why did you get it so big hey that's
what she said I think Halloween is for
jerks
well this Halloween I was the jerk I'm
sorry about tonight I'm sorry about
tonight
we found the title for Santiago's
follow-up sex tape I'm sorry I couldn't
convince you to love Halloween it's not
your fault I was terrible it's not your
fault I was terrible is also one of your
sex tapes Halloween is unbearable but it
was slightly less unbearable with you
don't force it in as deep as you can one
more but and you will be in contempt one
mark on your contempt name your sex tape
does the skin look red and swollen
that's what she said that's my joke damn
it Dwight I love guns I'm gonna make
such a good dad
not even gonna touch that the Amy
Santiago story that's what she said
I don't get a week blast of cold air
coming out of that box
name of Amy's sex tape hey man come on
not cool how about the Phyllis Angela
dispute
you already did me that's what she said
I've been looking but I can't find
anything and I don't know what to do I
can't find anything and I don't know
what to do
title of your sex tape so $300 do me the
hell's X the only gavel I could find
squeaks when you bang him that's what
she said I know liam awaits my dear i
know undercover evidence starting to get
real nervous about this contest you need
to see a therapist it's dance this way
how did you manage to step on both of my
feet at the same time I'm horrible at
this one can we stop I'm horrible at
this Mike no I know title of my sex tape
hey buttercup that's what she said
champagne mixed with thirty-year-old
scotch and top-shelf tequila captain
said a two-drink maximum
smort hmm oh god it's horrible yeah
shouldn't have added the olive juice ooh
okay so listen the thing I said to you
before I went undercover about how I
wish something had happened between us
romantically that wasn't nothing that
was real what are you saying
I know that you're with teddy I'm not
trying to change that and I get their
stuff I can't control but this morning I
told you that I didn't mean any of it
and that was a lie
I just don't want to hold anything back
well thank you for saying that just as
long as we're clear that I'm with
someone and nothing is gonna happen I'm
with someone nothing's gonna happen Amy
your sex tape
he's back and up comes the toolbar
that's what she said what do you have to
say for yourself the whole NYPD knows
where you are and they're coming for you
right now
okay thanks for the tip let's kill them
both get out of here before the cops
come wait no no no I was lying about the
backup I came alone tangled my sex tape
can you make that straighter that's what
she said did you plan that
no can you make that straighter that job
looks hard you should put your mouth on
that how can you even use that one
naturally okay look I hate to ask this
but have you considered shutting the
truck down you're always bragging about
how much Boyles love to give up I can't
I'm in so much debt I took out a loan
for the truck I got Amy to invest you
know the only way out of this fool is to
keep digging that's not how holes work
title your sex tape Dwight get out of my
nook that's what she said that's what
she said why don't we take this map and
this sextant and chart a course to the
restaurant title of your sex tape I did
not work at all but I loved that you
attempted it title of your sextant tape
all right let's go I'm sorry fuzed I
don't know what's happening right now
I'm so confused I don't know what's
happening right now title your sex tape
oh my god I'm shaking I'm definitely
gonna cry title your sex tape that's
what she said oh my god uh sorry I think
feeling a little awkward yeah meet you
how do we make it not weird I know
let's just get super drunk yes great
idea pardon me ma'am could you please
bring us four kamikaze shots and four
for me as well ah I like your style see
we can do this we're back on track we're
keeping it light and breezy so we broke
a rule yeah I hope it wasn't a mistake
hope it wasn't a mistake title your sex
tape title of our sex tape no no I need
two men on this that's what she said no
time what she did no time guys get on
this how do you explain this I have no
idea I put the plaque in my office Jedi
come here come here come here baby hell
yeah thank you return to my office
please
what's up you little turds wait what is
going on we have the plaque yeah I just
got out of the venture rub it in your
faces I just got it out of the venture
rub it in your faces name your sex tape
what's your office is full of genitalia
oh hey so is lo que da el that's what he
says Mitch well crack it wanna go grab
some coffee
great hey yeah I know that it's just us
there's a thing I wanted to say yeah
does that you why doesn't your mouth
work why doesn't your mouth work title
of our sex tape your sex tape what No
Oh it'll be here in ten years that's
what I said that's what she said
that's a who's that I never know I just
say it I say stuff like down you know to
lighten the tension when things sort of
get hard that's what she said hey nice
you're getting married right here right
now
what come on boy I don't even have a
dress you could wear Gina's I'm sure
it's white there's no way Gina was gonna
wear a white dress to my wedding no I
definitely was but I thought you'd just
wear a gray pants suit or something I
would never wear a great pant suit to
your wedding I promise you that this is
happening chickeny are getting married
tonight thought oh my sex tape huh yeah
I gotta look for work what and you were
directly under her the entire time
that's what she said
excuse me that's what she said miss
Levinson tells you that she was your
direct superior what why would she say
that
wait I don't understand who's on record
as saying this with all due respect I'm
in the middle of the line of questioning
now mr. Scott
what did you say miss Levinson said
regarding your employment status with
respect to her corporate position come
again
that's what she said I don't know you
if I may he was just telling a joke
before so I may move on to another
question are you sure yes can you go
back to where this digression began mr.
Schneider and you were directly under
her the entire time
mr. Scott that's what she said
deliveries all wrong butchering it
Santiago yes before you go both of you
requested to have this Saturday off but
I need one of you to work I can take
that shift the last time you worked a
Saturday you watch the cartoons the
entire time well that's when you're on
work this out and get back to me sorry I
can't reschedule I have tickets to a TED
talk on power poses and getting what you
want by using your body uh-oh hope it
doesn't get too sexual
oh I hope it doesn't get too sexual
title your sex tape but seriously what
is taking so long
also the title your sex tape all right
oh this is gonna feel so good getting
this thing off my chest
I can't be there for you I'm sorry Jim I
just really wish there was something I
could do
I can't believe you came
you